that idea of hierarchy and the divine
spark of consciousness and its
relationship to ultimate reality and and
to metaphysical reality that's
fundamentally what's under assault at
the universities it's far deeper than
the political needs to me I think this
has happened this is mostly
characteristic of the humanities and to
a lesser degree of the social sciences
but increasingly will become
characteristic of the STEM fields
because they're under assault I would
say by the same agents who undermined
the humanities and the social sciences
and I would say of all the dangers that
the current situation in the university
presents that's probably the one that's
primary because so far the STEM fields
have remained relatively let's say
unviolated by the intellectual
corruption that characterizes the other
disciplines and they're there of crucial
importance obviously practically
speaking but also as a bulwark against
the ideological pathology that currently
passes for academic knowledge in you
know in that Institutes of higher
education what's wrong exactly all right
it I really see it as a continuation of
a process that was identified by both
Nietzsche and Dostoevsky at the end of
the 19th century that it's a it's a
continuation of the collapse of the
collapse of the idea of God or collapse
and the belief in God or maybe if you
thought about it psychologically as a
collapse in the archetype of do
masculinity that's another way of
thinking about it we Nietzsche warned
that if we lost our fundamental
foundation block which was the notion of
about of a of a transcendent divinity
that we would degenerate in two
directions one direction being nihilism
and the other direction being it's its
twin its malformed twin totalitarianism
and that was his diagnosis for the 20th
century and I think that's exactly what
happened during the 20th century it's a
diagnosis of stunning accuracy
especially given how relatively early in
the 19th century it was made and
Dostoyevsky for his part made exactly
the same case particularly in in The
Devil's the possessed the books
variously titled which is a study of the
corrosive effects of really of an
ideology very very similar to the one
that reigns today in the university
campuses the devil's is is a literary
work that describes the intellectual and
moral genesis of exactly the type of
thinker who caused the catastrophes of
the Russian Revolution it would be 30
years later I guess so it's another work
of incredibly prescient insight almost
incomprehensible with the loss of that
see the problem with the loss of that
idea and I'm speaking psychologically I
would say which is what I try to do as
much as possible is that there
regardless of your religious belief you
cannot exist outside a hierarchy of
value it's not technically possible
you need a hierarchy of value to
organize your perceptions and IIIi mean
this I mean this literally I mean this
neural physiologically in that even when
you're observing the world which as far
as you're concerned merely manifests
itself for your observation you're
focusing your eyes are engaged in a
series of complex movements that are
controlled by unbelievably complicated
neural neuro physiological circuits and
you focus on something and not on
everything else and that means that you
pick something out of the almost
infinitely complex realm of potential
phenomena as of signal importance and
that Orient's your very capacity to
observe the world and that hierarchical
structure that guides your perceptions
is is of unbelievable depth and
complexity because you you tend to
attend to those things that let's say
you regard as important they're going to
further you in life so you need a
philosophy of what constitutes
furtherance in life which implies a
gradient between what's undesirable and
what's desirable and that that structure
that gradient of undesirable to
desirable is in fact the philosophical
manifestation of the neurophysiological
hierarchy that enables you to parse the
world up so that it's comprehensible and
something has to be at the top of that
well it doesn't because you can be a war
you can be an internal war of
conflicting values that's the
alternative but that's not
psychologically acceptable that's that
would manifest itself in uncertainty and
anxiety and directionless 'no sand
hopelessness and nihilism to be housed
that's divided amongst itself all of
that needs
be oriented into a hierarchy that's a
unity and something has to be at the
pinnacle of the hierarchy because
otherwise it's not a hierarchy and and
the question is well what is it that
might be at the pinnacle and and that is
the question it's it's the question
right it's it because what's at the
pinnacle is that to which all of your
resources should be fundamentally
devoted and what we decided in the West
over thousands of years and I would say
beginning far before Christianity was
that there was an ideal mode of being
that's expressed in the idea that human
beings have a spark of divinity within
and that and that manifesting the
personality that would be the most
genuine embodiment of that spark of
divinity constitutes the highest of
possible goals and you know you can you
can simplify that idea you could say
well you know you you have an ethical
responsibility to manifest what's best
in you to manifest your potential people
speak in those terms and to become more
than you are to become who you could be
but lurking underneath that is this idea
of the ideal the ideal the embodied
ideal or even the incarnate ideal
because this is something that's not
merely an abstraction it's something
that's expressed in flesh that's the
idea of the word made flesh let's say
that's it's part of the same set of
ideas and that that that ethical
proposition is that I think it's
expressed well in in the earliest
chapters of Genesis the ethical
proposition is something like there's a
there's an action in the world there's
an action in being that's characterized
in Christianity as logos and it's the
operation of truth and courage nested in
love on
Henschel so the idea in Genesis is the
world springs into being in some sense
as a consequence of the action of this
logos and that if the logos is operative
on potential then what emerges as a
consequence is good by definition so
that's an ethical it's an ethical axiom
it's a daring ethical accident it's it's
it's one of the most daring ideas I've
ever come across because it's a very
daring idea to to State deposit because
in the absence of proof accept that
which you would gather as a consequence
of enacting the proposition that if you
act courageously and you tell the truth
then what you bring into being is by
definition good so it doesn't look that
way you can get into a lot of trouble by
telling the truth and so it's very easy
to take the easy way out in the short
term that that's the characteristic of
God himself and it's and the logos is
the characteristic of the logos is the
definition for the process that
undertakes that extraction from
potential and its transformation into
reality and then there's the secondary
proposition that human beings are made
in the image of God and I believe and I
also believe this as a scientist that
there isn't a more accurate way of
describing what we do as conscious
beings you know you hear that if you're
adequately informed scientific
materialist that it's incumbent on you
to note that human beings are
fundamentally deterministic in their
behavior but the evidence for that I
would say is not strong the conceptual
evidence is strong because you can make
a coherent argument but the actual
evidence is rather weak because it isn't
obvious at all that we can act
deterministically except when we've done
things that we've practiced intensely
but that isn't the way that the world
manifests itself to us in many ways what
what seems to be the case instead is
that we wake up every morning
and what faces us is the unformed future
that's the reality that we confront it's
not the present and it's not the past
its what could be that day and and we
see that as a field of possibility all
of which could conceivably be manifested
but none of which has yet been
manifested and and and then we feel
called upon as the action of our life to
chart a course through that multitude of
potential paths to select from among all
those possibilities the realities that
we choose to bring into being and then
to work to bring them into being and we
also recognize and we treat each other
like this that the quality of what it is
that's brought into being as a
consequence of those choices is directly
dependent on the ethical integrity with
which we conducted ourselves while
making those choices which is why we can
wake up at 3:00 in the morning and
berate ourselves for having made a mess
of the week or the day or the month or
our lives because we understand that
we've deviated from the appropriate path
and we call ourselves out on it like we
call out the people we love and the
people that we have relationships with
and that idea is is that's that idea
that idea of hierarchy and the divine
spark of consciousness and its
relationship to ultimate reality and and
to metaphysical reality that's
fundamentally what's under assault at
the universities it's far deeper than
the political it's it's